Cool.
So, we're just doing a super quick
stream here, like 40 minutes. Um, and
then I got a meeting, but I am going on
vacation unplanned uh last minute. So, I
will be out for
a week, maybe two, and uh then I will be
not at this facility thereafter for a
little while. So, I figured I'd get a
quick stream in. We're going to take a
quick look at the vectorzation thing
that I started on um last stream and
we're going to see if we get anywhere
like super super quick.
All right, so
we're on 40.
Take a look at end of binding here. So
the idea was uh Oh yeah, we're doing
this. The goal is 40 minutes, fix
[clears throat] this thing, redesign
Vec, and also see if I PR my deadlift.
That's my short stream goal.
At least raw PR.
So, uh, let me go over the plan real
quick. So, I think I have it solid in my
head. Um, right now I tried to do this
super weird thing in which I had one uh
one like atomic
tracker per I believe per thread. Yes,
per thread. And what I was trying to do
is I was trying to keep track of the
index of work for each of these threads.
That is bad. What I should have done
instead is keep track uh one atomic int
for each buffer, not for each thread. Uh
buffers are a fixed amount of work. So
you can literally just have uh have the
threads count down from that buffer. So
the way that this is going to look is
uh thread grabs a chunk of work and
uh yeah, thread grabs a chunk of work.
It
does the work. It counts down the uh
amount of work remaining for that buffer
which is an easy modulo operation to
compute. And I believe from there it is
fine. Um
and I don't think I can see any race
conditions with that. I think we're just
good. So that is the design roughly
speaking. Uh, let me try.
I think I'm going to just do
375.
I think I'll just go for this and then
this will be warm up and we'll get we'll
see if I can get out from here.
That felt pretty pretty decent.
So, I think I can actually try to PR it
today. We'll see. Um,
all right. So,
for this thing here, what do we have?
This is
completion indices. Um,
so we're going to do
This is going to be buffer tasks.
Hey Fabian, what's going to be the new
PR? We we will see.
It's not going to be a total like weight
PR because this is raw and my old PRs
are from when I was literally 20 lbs
heavier. Um and also belt and straps.
Hey Liberty, super quick stream. We are
we're rewriting uh the VEC
one piece of the ve threading with a new
architecture
slightly new architecture.
We also need to figure out
Yep. So we also need to make sure that
this is
Okay, there's a condition here I have to
figure out.
Yeah, new haircut. Um,
so we basically we need to make sure
this buffer was actually loaded.
Oh, can we just do
Actions ready on GPU?
What was the original goal? I didn't
give it enough time, man. So the
original goal was to have a thing where
you steer atoms around and you maximize
the property uh like a specific measured
property. Uh the outcome of that was
that the material science package lamps
was really not at all designed to be
interacted with uh programmatically.
Like their C API was literally just exec
of a string command for everything you
wanted to do. So, I didn't get really
far. It was really opaque. It was really
tough to work with. Um, material science
is still like a top three thing in my in
like what I'd like to see RL applied to
though.
Okay. So this is
this is here
and then we do was this end index
comic.
Let me go double check the Whoops. The
atomic.
I mean, if you RL a new material, I
think that would be pretty nutty.
Why when I Google C do I get the [ __ ]
C++ docs?
Okay, so we store buffer tasks
block size,
right?
Yeah, that sounds good.
And then here
dude. Like, you don't say computer
science when somebody asks you what
you're studying. You give them the
specific area.
This is like I remember there was this
one dude at MIT who uh was at the EECS
department like entry thing for new PhD
students. And I said, "So what do you
study?" And then he said, "Ah, I stud I
work in ECS."
And then he looked very proud of
himself. I was just like, "You are the
stupidest [ __ ] I've ever met.
[laughter]
So, don't do that.
At least tell people like I'm an AI or
like yeah, I work on drones or I work on
something, man.
All right, there's your block start.
We do this C step and then what we have
to do we do um
basically doing most of CS at the
moment.
Yeah. But like typically you know
you are doing something other than
taking core courses, right?
What is this supposed to be? This is
block start divided by
Well, we'll just do like this percent
num ms.
That still felt pretty easy. The only
thing is um I have to sit down
immediately or I will pass out. So
I'm actually the thing I'm happiest
about is the grip feels really easy. Um
gripping that weight used to be very
very difficult for me. How do you speed
up? Do you mind have pixel library?
They just spend money, dude. There's no
magical solution. They just spent a [ __ ]
ton of money.
Just add these things to threading real
quick.
Yo, Wednesday I seen podcast coming out.
I don't know. We posted the one with B
Yeah.
I mean, he gave like a a 10-minute
intro, but it's like, oh, whatever. You
know, he likes Puffer.
Is not broke.
What's going on?
this have a CUDA check on it.
Yeah.
thing is plenty big. Alec,
how on earth is this egg fing? That's
weird.
huh? Oh, something is just totally
screwed, I suppose.
Yeah. Yeah, something has just like I
guess broken the compiler or something.
I'll figure that out.
Okay. Um,
we try PR again.
Well, you shall see.
This would be um I've never pulled this
raw, I will say.
right. That's the most annoying alarm
ever
there.
lbs.
I'm very happy with that.
2.35. Not quite 2.5.
Still though,
I'm happy with that.
I was going to wait a couple more weeks
before attempting that, but I'm going on
vacation, so I figured it was now or
never.
Comments not visible cuz I didn't flip
the screen back over, man.
I'm not going to do a max bench though.
I haven't been training bench heavy
enough before I go. So, I think we'll
keep it as um 210 for 10 is best set.
I'm happy with this. Um I mean all the
puffer progress, all the training
progress
been a productive couple of months.
Let's see if we can figure this out real
quick before I end stream. I got a
meeting at um at 4. This was just a
quick stream. I figured I'd like
implement this new architecture real
quick.
BIPR deadlift
and that's about it. No, I'm going on
vacation for a week, week and a half and
then after that I'll go to Florida.
most likely
might go through New York. We'll see.
Oh yeah, this is totally some weird
compile screw up if it's not even
getting to this right.
I'm actually not even sure what the heck
this would be.
Did we fail to open the um
Oh.
Yeah. Okay. So something is just like
completely
unless I was just forgetting the null
term.
Okay.
Unless I was just being dumb and
forgetting to know term.
Apparently I was.
Where's Where is this thing failing?
I don't know how I managed to do that.
That thread's done. Cool. So, this
actually all runs.
It threads. Ah, okay. So
this fails
in this somehow.
this fails in this somehow. This feels like this is um
This feels like this is um
an end bug, right? What's the best way
to support Puffer Lib? I guess you have
no super chat. Yeah, I am not like
honestly donations at the levels of
individuals do not help the project at
all. Um
you know, we charge we charge clients
like very reasonable amounts for stuff.
Um, so it's really the way to get
involved is just contribute to the open
source, learn some RL. If you're
interested in professional side stuff
and you're and you get good enough to,
you know, meaningfully do those types of
jobs, there are opportunities there as
well.
But pretty much just enjoy the project,
build some stuff, PR some stuff, you
know, try to learn
how it goes.
[sighs and gasps] So I I'm pretty sure I
just broke the end somehow. Um because
this doesn't make any sense to me.
Hey Peru.
I think I got the new design for this
thing, but it's bugged.
Yesterday was torture.
Nice, my dude. That's what happened. I'm
getting out of here. I got my flight out
tomorrow while they deal with
No.
[ __ ] that.
Going to catch them, get them out, and
plug whatever the hell holes they got in
through.
Oops. I got to get ready to go to uh my
meeting in a couple minutes. This is
just a short stream.
Florida. Vacation's not in Florida. I
got myself uh I got myself some tickets
somewhere nice. Um I'm go chill for a
week and a half or so and then I'll be
back to work. I needed a break anyways.
So, this is divine intervention in some
sense.
Okay. I have no idea what I broke here.
Um, I'll try to fix this after dinner if
I manage. I might do an after dinner
stream. We'll see. I'm not not making
any promises. I got a pack as well.
Might miss notification. Thanks, Peru. I
There's a slight redesign of it anyways,
but I'll take a look. Okay, so for folks
watching, I mean, the main thing is I
wanted to do do this stream just to tell
people. Um, so we got the new design for
the end of binding thing. That'll be
done hopefully soon. I'll be back in a
week and a halfish. Uh maybe two. And
then we're going to finish the 40
update. Once I'm back going to finish
Vec, we're going to finish all the new
optimization. We're going to finish
constellation and then aim to get a
release in knowish Q1. So if you're
interested in my work, thanks for tuning
in. I usually do much longer streams
than this. Uh you can support the
project for absolutely free by starring
the repository.
feed the puffer. You want to get
involved with development, join the
Discord, discord.gg/puffer.
And other than that, you can follow me
on X for more RL content. Thank you.